[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for the
first first overall pick of the jags
trevor lawrence joining us on the
program you know i was wondering you
just got there
how difficult is it to uh try to
remember everybody's name
it's hard yeah i'm trying to do that
right now i've learned a lot of a lot of
the guys and a lot of the whole
just buildings names of all the people
staff everyone
uh that's something that's important to
me so it's been hard it's like going to
you know your first day of school or
something and trying to remember
everyone's name
okay but how do you fool people if you
don't know their names what's your go to
well i mean honestly people that i'm
even really close with i'm not calling
them
by name that much anyway so it's always
like what's up man
i already kind of talked like that or
what's up dude
i already do that so it doesn't really
sound any different anyways which is
which is good but yeah i definitely
don't like that feeling of not knowing
someone's name
what was your second best sport
second best sport uh probably basketball
i mean i
i wasn't great i was okay but i really i
really liked playing basketball
that was the one other sport that i
actually played kind of like just for
fun
when i wasn't playing football so i've
always really
really loved playing basketball but
you're tall
you're expected to be good yeah i'm okay
i could shoot a little bit i'm one of
those guys that was tall but really like
to shoot and try to handle the ball i
wasn't very good at it but that's like
what i wanted to do
i didn't want to get in there and get
rebounds who plays
basketball the way you played in high
school
um it's a hard question
i'd nobody probably i'd be playing
basketball if i played like anyone
well well no had a similar game like
that guy you know just shot out
a tall guy like dirk nowitzki like uh
i i guess that's a lofty uh comparison
so i guess that you could use that
who's the defender that you look forward
to playing against
um to be honest i haven't really i mean
there's
so many great ones i haven't really been
focused on one guy
uh from a specific team that i'm looking
forward to playing against i've been
trying to
excuse this learning curve and prepare
us as well as i can
to be ready so i haven't even really
thought about it but there's a there's a
ton of good ones so
it's going to be fun so um i know we
play in la this year so
there's a lot of there's a lot of guys
from each team that it's going to be a
fun challenge
what about former teammates who now get
a chance to hit you
oh that's one and that was the first one
i should have said i
actually talked to christian wilkins who
play
you know we played the dolphins in in
london so i
uh take him
that's a veteran move on your part there
yeah
he wasn't going for it so we'll see when
did you start to think that you could be
an nfl quarterback
like what age uh i don't know honestly i
think probably sometime in high school
that became more realistic and something
i really was
thinking more about accomplishing um
as a kid though i'd be the first to say
it wasn't really like
a dream of mine necessarily i don't even
think i went that far it was more
i just want to be a college quarterback
that was what i grew up watching i
didn't watch as much nfl as i did
college
so that was kind of always my dream was
i want to go to a big big school and
play quarterback
and then as i got older and that became
okay i'm going to do that that's kind of
the next step
and then it's looking forward like let's
see how far we can
take this so probably sometime in high
school sophomore freshman sophomore year
i'm
not really sure who's funnier urban
meyer or
dabo it depends
what kind of sense of humor you are
[Music]
i think coach coach sweeney here coach
sweeney is funnier to laugh at
for sure yeah i think then coach meyer
coach sweeney's just goofy um
coach coach meyer is a little bit more
dry sense of humor
but he's he's awesome so both are
different but
similar in the way they lead and it's
been it's been interesting getting to
see the
different personalities but i really
have a ton of respect and
enjoy being around both of them he's
trevor lawrence the jegs quarterback
um what happened on draft night where
you didn't have your your phone on
the jags are trying to call no i had i
had it on i don't know what happened
um i didn't get the calls so i my my
place in clemson is
the service is terrible i'm out kind of
in the woods uh
far out there so i guess they just
didn't get to me because i was sitting
there
waiting on them uh kind of got nervous
there for a second
did you get nervous at all i mean did
you did you start to think
oh my gosh you know maybe they're taking
zach wilson
no not really i was uh i didn't i didn't
really
i didn't really sweat it too much but i
was i didn't know that they tried to
call me until i got there the next day
when i was visiting and they were like
dude we i guess we either had the wrong
number or whatever they called me from
coach meyer's phone
so no i wouldn't i wasn't too worried i
was just like dang it's a long
10 minutes to sit here and wait on
someone to call you
it's not how the process is supposed to
go um
did you did you have a honeymoon did you
have time for a honeymoon
no not yet we're planning on um taking
one
in july when we get a little bit of time
but we stayed at the wedding venue for a
couple days after we got married
and then just it was such a crazy time i
really didn't have time to go take a
week or so and just
be alone so we're looking forward to
doing that later this summer
when you were a gatorade player of the
year what did that kind of signify
to you it's just
it was the first time i guess i was
really
represented if you if you'll say that by
a brand like gatorade
you know such a such a big brand that
i've been around since i was a kid that
i've loved
um and then kind of combining that with
my high school my team all that you know
the success i was able to have
it was really special and um
yeah i was just able i'm sure it's kind
of where you're leading i was just able
to
present the 2021 gatorade
national football player of the year to
jackson yesterday
so that was really special and cool to
be a part of kind of on the other side
of that
and just really cool to be able to spend
a little bit of time with him this is
the
the biggest and best high school sports
award there is so
for me to you know i was the state
player of the year to be a part of that
when i was in high school then
turn around four years later three or
four years later whatever it is
and be able to present it to someone
national player of the year was really
it was really cool
yeah jackson dart he's uh out of utah
and i know that he's a usc recruit that
that sounds like
like a quarterback's name like you're
throwing darts right
pretty cool name quarterback yeah
uh we're about uh seven or eight minutes
in i haven't asked uh
tim tebow question are you impressed by
that
uh that might be the record
okay do you have a statement prepared is
there a question that you
want me to ask about tebow that you're
prepared to answer
i'm a i'm an open book you know i don't
you can ask whatever it's not going to
surprise me
have you practiced with tim i have we've
gotten
three practices in together now i think
i believe it was third last
thursday um monday and yesterday
so what do you what are your impressions
he looks good
uh i mean he's in great shape he's
running well you can tell he's been
training
uh he came in here and he's in great
shape like i said and then
i think just mentally he's picking
everything up
really quickly i think it helps him that
he played quarterback and he's learned a
few different systems and
have you yelled at him yet because the
quarterback gets to yell at people
no no no i haven't uh i haven't i
haven't got to yet he's been
really he's been awesome um people have
been asking me and
everything they and i i didn't know tim
at all until i met him last week
actually so i never even talked to him
we've had a few good conversations and
everything that you hear about him from
what i've been able to tell is true you
know great character
just a guy you want to be around you
want to have around your team
just because he brings another element
and just a guy that's been through a lot
and has won and has done it at a high
level it's it's it's cool to be around
that and a guy that was so
big when i first started getting into
into football you know i was probably 10
or 11 when he was at florida
so it's really cool now it's just weird
like being his teammate now is
it's a interesting dynamic but have you
said to him hey
i grew up watching you like which
probably
i haven't we we've been talking about a
lot of different a lot of other
different things but
and i hadn't really thought about it
until someone asked me a couple days ago
and i was like
dang you know this is the guy i grew up
watching and playing with on like
ncaa games and stuff so it is weird so
you were tebow playing video games yeah
yeah
at some point yeah hey uh good luck
uh gonna be quite a journey there but uh
man
got urban meyer though on your side now
you're used to going against urban now
he's on your side no doubt we got a
we got a good group we're really excited
everyone's been working hard so
we're excited for this year it's going
to be a lot of fun thank you trevor and
good luck we appreciate your time
thank you dan i appreciate it man trevor
lawrence learn more about the gatorade
player of the year program
visit playeroftheyear.gatorade.com